les matins de france culture 7h 9h
guillaume erner 7h42 et dans le cadre
des matinales politique de l'équipe des
temps de parole nous recevons gérard
larcher bonjour bonjour vous êtes
président du sénat et membre du parti
l'est républicain gérard larcher comme
vous êtes président je vais vous poser
une question mitterrandienne comment va
la france
c'est à dire la france est profondément
divisée fracturée et je tire de mes
déplacements très nombreux dans le pays
du sentiment que les n'a pas commencé il
ya deux ans et demi ou trois ans d'un
pays où une partie de nos concitoyens
prix entre métropolisation
financiarisation mondialisation a le
sentiment d'être à côté je l'avais écrit
à françois hollande après le drame des
attentats de 2015 selon lui aviez dit
bon je lui avais dit qu'il partie du
pays ne se sentait plus à la table de la
république et j'avais à ce moment-là
pris l'exemple de ce qui m'a été
l'interpellation dans un territoire
pauvre du pas de calais monsieur le
président pourquoi vous ne faites des
lois que pour quelques métropoles
quelques régions puissante et puis plus
récemment dans l'allier est un élu qui
m'a dit est ce que vous vous rendez
compte que moulins et montluçon sont
beaucoup plus loin paris que paris n'ait
de londres de barcelone ou d'amsterdam
je crois que c'est cette réalité là ça
s'est traduit par la crise des gilets
jours de la révolte des ronds points
mais aussi cette crispation d'ailleurs
ce soutien encore aujourd'hui à la
démarche des grévistes alors qu'est ce
qui se passe par exemple à moulins
montluçon ou ailleurs gérard larcher
qu'est ce qui explique qu'une partie de
la république ne se sent pas précisément
est bien entouré par la république
je prends un exemple nous avons une
croissance aujourd'hui qui est ce
qu'elle est 1,3 elle profite
essentiellement quelques métropoles une
partie du pays continue réellement se
dévitalise et et ce sentiment là est un
sentiment qui aujourd'hui conduit à une
forme de maladie voilà pourquoi le
président de la république nous devons
tous ensemble je disais aux sénateurs
que nous qui représentons les
territoires soyons des réducteurs de
fracture
fracture territoriale fracture sociale
et la verticalité du pouvoir est
aujourd'hui inadapté à cette réparation
des fractures mais alors la fracture
territoriale
elle se traduit comment par exemple je
ne sais pas les services publics gérard
larcher santé par exemple j'étais en
région cendres il ya quelques semaines
aujourd'hui en matière de santé de
présence médicale sur le territoire nous
sommes dans un déficit assez incroyable
mon propre département qui connaît les
ive et d'un certain monde question
présence médicale mais j'ose le dire ça
n'est rien à côté de ce qu'ils
ressentent ils tout près dans le
département de l'eure où dans le
département de l'yonne
cette réalité de la santé avait
d'ailleurs sauté au visage du président
de la république lors du grand débat ce
thème qui ne faisait pas partie des
questionnements du grand débat pascal
perrineau le rappeler c'est le deuxième
thème qui s'est imposé lors du grand
débat alors ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire dire qu'il faudrait par exemple
investir à nouveau dans la santé parce
que vous appartenez au parti des
républicains gérard larcher a priori les
républicains ou en tout cas la droite
française n'est pas connu pour investir
dans les infrastructures les services
publics
d'abord c'est inexact en même temps il
nous faut maîtriser la dépense publique
mais la réponse n'est pas que
d'investissement elle est aussi
d'investissements dans les hommes de
politiques territoriales qui permettent
notamment la présence médicale sur le
territoire la réforme des études
médicales est quelque chose de tout à
fait essentiel pour que dans la réforme
médicale une partie de la formation a
lieu sur le territoire
il ne suffira pas de construire des
maisons de santé pluridisciplinaires
investissement si on n'a pas des
médecins ou des infirmières à mettre
dans ses besoins alors les médecins on
comprend les hôpitaux vous en feriez
quoi gérard larcher notamment ses
hôpitaux qui sont présentés comme des
hôpitaux de proximité souvent dans les
zones rurales où les fermes et voulaient
regrouper vous en feriez quoi j'en fais
d'abord des hôpitaux de proximité pour
répondre aux besoins médicaux dans la
proximité mais nous savons tous qu'il
faut que vous aimez le nez en l'air de
compétences que on pourra pas faire
partout
de chirurgie où j'allais dire des soins
intensifs
c'est donc la mise en réseau de ces
établissements mais pas leur disparition
par rapport au territoire d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui les hôpitaux on le voit au
travers des services d'urgence
c'est-à-dire la crise d urgence ils sont
en train de répondre à au déficit de
présence médicale et notamment de ce
qu'on appelle la médecine de ville ou de
campagne mais là c'est ce que le
gouvernement fait ou c'est ce qui ne
fait pas dans le plan santé 2022 que
nous avons d'ailleurs voté 2 au sénat
c'est une des réponses mais je crois
qu'il faut qu'on aille beaucoup plus
loin
moi je pense j'ai jadis présidait les
hôpitaux publics dans ce pays parce que
je très attaché au service public
hospitalier
je pense que la question des hôpitaux
aujourd'hui est aussi une question
statutaire il faut plus d'autonomie aux
établissements
nous vivons dans les hôpitaux comme
ailleurs à système très recentraliser
très centralisé dans lequel sur le faux
tous décident d'en haut en fait tout
commence avenue de ségur et les agences
régionales de santé ne sont que la
courroie de transmission pour des
directeurs qui ne sont que les
exécutants redonnant redonnant à
l'initiative territoriales une place
voilà pourquoi je prône une nouvelle
génération de la décentralisation dans
le domaine de la santé dans le domaine
de l'emploi dans le domaine de la
gestion des collectivités président de
la république s'y était engagé dans sa
conférence de presse du printemps
dernier on va le mettre en oeuvre je
l'espère cette année mais alors
justement ce sentiment de fractures
parce qu'il n'est pas seulement liée aux
zones rurales
il y en aura blement il vient d'où
gérard larcher est ce qu'il est
seulement liés aux infrastructures à la
question spital hier il ya aussi
d'autres questions qui sont évoqués par
des manifestants et les différentes
colère qu'on aperçoit en france
aujourd'hui il est lié aussi à une
réalité je vous parlais de la croissance
la croissance se situent essentiellement
sur les pôles métropolitains une partie
du pays continuent à se dévitalise et à
ne pas proposer d'espérance et ça n'est
pas qu'une fracture entre zones rurales
et et métropole et je n'oppose pas les
uns aux autres nous avons besoin de
métropole dynamique et puissante
mais nous avons tout un réseau de villes
moyennes de bourg centre il ya un
certain nombre de parties de territoire
vous allez en truites son élan où vous
allez dans d'autres parties dans mes de
la sens et vous regardez vous traversez
des petites villes des villages de
rideau sur quatre des commerces ont
fermé des marques et à vendre partout
regardez les classements scolaire dans
ces territoires
il ya une partie du pays qui quelque
part est en marche de la république
ce qui m'intéresse par rapport à ce
constat gérard larcher encore une fois
je rappelle que est vous faites partie
des républicains a priori la droite
française elle est censée être peu
interventionniste quand on a des
commerces parliez d'hirson en tirage
donc dans des zones qui sont quand même
très frappé par effectivement taux de
chômage une paupérisation
comment faire pour cueillir son y ait
autre chose que des commerces qui
ferment puisqu'on sait qu'il ya comme
partout d'ailleurs la périphérie qui
drainent vers des centres commerciaux et
une activité économique restreinte
le gaulliste que je suis croit
l'intervention publique
je pense que le bon niveau de
aujourd'hui ce sont les collectivités
territoriales car ce sont elles qui sont
en proximité et parmi eux lire les
éléments de la crise que vous évoquez au
début de ce pays fracturé il y a le
sentiment qu'il n'y aurait plus de
proximité entre les citoyens les
décideurs d'ailleurs faut pas s'y
tromper et seul élu aujourd'hui qu'on la
confiance majoritaire des français ce
sont les maires et maires adjoints les
conseillers municipaux
pourquoi parce qu'ils sont en proximité
y compris pour recevoir j'allais dire
les interrogations les plaintes
je pense que si on a les moyens qui ne
se représente c'est quand même un peu
moins moi n'exagérons pas mais il est
vrai qu'ils ont connu un mandat
horribilis aurait dit la reine
d'angleterre
ces six années baisse des dotations et
le sentiment un moment de mépris
vis-à-vis des mères souvenez-vous le
président de la république a même oublié
qu'ils avaient eu un congrès des maires
il s'est rattrapé en 2019 parce qu entre
temps
il ya eu la crise dite des gilets jaunes
il ya eu un grand débat et c'est les
maires de france qui ont tenu la
république pendant quelques semaines
sylvain tesson l'écrivain dit que la
france est un paradis où les gens se
croient en enfer qu'est ce que vous en
pensez gérard larcher il est vrai que ce
n'est pas l'enfer y compris quand
j'entends une ancienne candidate à la
présidence de la république nous
expliquer que nous serions une dictature
ou à un régime dictatorial dont je crois
que c'est eux qui disaient heureux comme
des français ont comme la cob en france
je crois que nous avons beaucoup
d'atouts dans notre pays
nous avons des atouts humains nous avons
des atouts territoriaux le territoire
est une chance nous avons un savoir
faire nous avons une culture une
éducation mais quelque part nous avons
besoin de nous retrouver en communauté
au singulier et non pas en communauté au
pluriel
je ne parle pas là que de réalité par
exemple à caractère religieux ou
philosophique nous avons besoin de
sentir que nous avons un destin commun à
partager le destin c'est le destin de
notre pays c'est le destin au travers de
l'europe c'est aussi le message que nous
devons apporter dans un monde lui même
tellement fracture est divisé et donc à
sortir de nos peurs quelle peur par
exemple quelle peur vous paraît
outrancière est ce qu'il s'agit des
reculs en peur de pareilles outrancière
elle me paraît tout simplement être un
symptôme la peur c'est un symptôme
à force de ne pas traiter les yeux dans
les yeux par exemple la question
migratoire avec ascenta nombre de pays
émetteurs de migration au fond nous
créons les crispations allez roger alors
que ce dossier il doit être abordée en
vérité dans un dialogue avec notamment
les pays émetteurs d'immigration c'est
ce que j'ai souhaité faire l'an dernier
au moment où je préside et laissez-la
d'europe en réunissant les deuxième
chambre d'afrique pour que nous parlions
ensemble de ces sujets du développement
de l'éducation
que nous parlions au cid ce qui
suscitait les phénomènes migratoires les
déstabilisations mais nous avons une
migration de l'eau actuellement dans un
certain nombre ce pays voilà les
réalités que nous devons traiter la
colère et la violence est ya de la
violence
aujourd'hui en france gérard larcher
lieu de la violence et nous voyons bien
et ça c'est inacceptable dans une
démocratie
nous le voyons dans un certain nombre de
manifestations nous le voyons aussi dans
un certain nombre d'expressions et
d'expression qui par exemple rejette
l'autre y compris quand il dit quelque
chose qui pourrait déranger telle ou
telle communauté ou tel ou tel servier a
précisé je pense précisément par exemple
moi qui suis très attaché à la loi de
1905 de ce qui se passe parfois sur la
question religieuse savez je suis très
marquée par aristide briand la loi doit
protéger la foi tant que la fois
n'entend pas dicter la loi et tous qui
réducteur de liberté dans un pays comme
le nôtre de liberté d'expression tu dois
faire d'ailleurs dans le respect de
l'autre et de ses convictions m'apparaît
quelque part un recul par rapport aux
valeurs profondes de notre pays la
violence dans les manifestations elle
vient des manifestants la police a
d'abord dû manifestants pardonnez moi on
peut manifester et on peut manifester
sans violence
on peut manifester en disant des choses
très très forte
détruire des vitrines s'attaquer aux
policiers relèvent d'un autre processus
que du droit absolu dans notre
constitution à faire grève et à
manifester
il y avait une manifestation de pompiers
on a vu des pompiers se battre je ne
sais pas quel autre mot employé avec des
policiers ça vous a inspiré quoi gérard
larcher première des choses pont c'est
une image qui me fait vraiment mal parce
que pompier policier gendarme nous les
voyons tellement sollicité sur le
terrain nous qui représentons les
territoires nous savons le rôle qu'il
joue
mais il ya une responsabilité de l'état
à force de ne pas traiter le malaise
aujourd'hui des sapeurs pompiers qui
relève d'un besoin de moyens mais pas
simplement financier mais de mai non pas
simplement financiers ils ont été
alloués de le dire le rappelait gérard
larcher mettez trois exemples sur la
question de la santé c'est les pompiers
qui jouent en lieu et place aujourd'hui
de la présence médicale
ce sont les premiers qui sont appelés
pour transféré aux urgences y compris
pour des petites pathologies
ils ne sont plus dans leur rôle qu'il
jouait notamment avec les abus et
aujourd'hui il remplace la
désertification médicale et ça devient
pour extrêmement difficile à porter mais
alors précisément puisque ces questions
d'aménagement du territoire elle se
heurte aujourd'hui un souci
supplémentaire qui est la préoccupation
écologique cette préoccupation
écologique est ce qu'elle ne freine pas
un toutes les tentatives que l'on
pourrait avoir de désenclaver les
territoires de construction
d'utilisation de la voiture
concrètement ça pourrait passer parcours
à gérard larcher je crois qu'il faut
propre opposé ses préoccupations
écologiques parce qu'à force de
concentrer le développement que sur une
partie du territoire en fait on a déduit
des déplacements qui eux mêmes choses
générateur de pollution je crois qu'il
faut retrouver une politique ça ne sera
que progressive déquilibre développement
du territoire et ce développement du thc
la nouvelle génération de la
décentralisation 80 de françois
mitterrand et gaston defferre y compris
en s'opposant la droite et au centre à
ce moment-là met en place une nouvelle
donne ça s'appelle la décentralisation
au fond ils vont faire confiance aux
élus du territoire
et ça marche alors naturellement ça
marche avec un certain nombre
d'interrogations
parfois même d'excès je pense à certains
excès de dépenses financières dans
lequel s'est pas tout à fait b ça
profondément transformé le pays ça rendu
le payant proximité et depuis dix ans
depuis dix ans à peu près nous assistons
une recentralisation
en fait nous avons progressivement vidé
l'état territorial les préfectures et
sous préfectures aux bénéfices d'agencés
nationales
inomineo un préfet ou un sous préfet on
peut dialoguer avec une agence de
l'habitat ou une agence d'économie
d'énergie vous savez pourquoi elles ont
été créées ces agences de l'habitat
elles ont été créés parce qu'on a
considéré que le niveau de la
municipalité au niveau supérieur n'avait
pas la gouvernance nécessaire pour
trancher les questions urbaines êtes
trompé on s'est trompé profondément
parce que c'est au niveau du territoire
suivant un principe inventé d'ailleurs
par les allemands qui s'appelle la
subsidiarité il ya très longtemps c'est
la réforme allemande qui la vend ce qui
se fait en proximité doit se faire en
proximité ce qui se fait en mutualisant
doit se faire en mutualisant ne me
croyez pas contre l'état quand je dis ça
mais le bon niveau d'intervention
ça peut sur les questions sociales et
même sur une grande partie de la santé
le département la région qu'elle
développe altarea prenons l'exemple de
l'urbanisme avec un problème qui est
celui de la densification du bâti
puisque c'est ça finalement qui provoque
les trajets les trajets trop longs
le fait qu'il y a aussi beaucoup de
colère parce que ces trajets trop longs
et bien il ne simplifie pas la vie et il
coûte gérard larcher est ce que ces
questions elles ont été bien traitées
par ce niveau qui est le niveau du
département
c'est pas le niveau du département le
niveau d'urbanistes le niveau
intercommunal et c'est le niveau des
schémas régionaux
donc c'est les deux niveaux avec l'état
au fonds plus on à recentraliser plus on
a eu des politiques qui ont était
incohérente par rapport à cette question
d'urbanisme regard et on a tourné dans
un texte national
vous faites des petits dessins nguyen
c'est à dire je prends mon carré jeu
densifie tu te démarche on peut
approuver et en même temps les mêmes qui
parlent d'écologie nous disent mais on
densifie trop les centres villes alors
que l'objectif c'est de ne pas consommer
de territoire et dans un dialogue
notamment avec les agriculteurs les
chambres d'agriculture nous savons
il ne faut pas consommer de territoire
agricole nous avons trop consommé de
territoire agricole
la réalité est la réponse aujourd'hui
c'est au niveau du territoire dans le
cadre de décisions qui sont prises
notamment par le parlement mais c'est là
où je doive se décliner les politiques
la région le département la commune avec
l'intercommunalité 7h 9h les matins de
france culture
guillaume erner est notre invité c'est
gérard larcher président du sénat et
membre du parti des républicains
mon camarade frédéric seysses a posé une
bonne question qu'est ce qu'être macro
nist selon vous en tous les cas je ne
sais pas il répond que je ne suis pas
macro dix ans nous avait annoncé la
formation à nouveau monde et on a tous
les symptômes du plus ancien monde ce
que je crois que la députée macro nist
doit se poser la question qu'est ce que
je représente un député comme un
sénateur mais un député ça représente en
direct les citoyens c'est une partie de
la légitimité nationale c'est la
représentation d'un territoire sa
circonscription à l'exception des
députés qui représentent les français
établis hors de france et il est là
pourquoi pour être en quelque sorte un
médiateur un intermédiaire pour faire la
loi et contrôler le gouvernement
c'est sa mission de députés tous les
cinq scènes de l'ancien monde dit vous
n'êtes pas un peu sévère écoutez je
crois que c'est même encore pire parce
que même le chef de l'état n'est plus le
chef a contesté regardez la réaction de
monsieur villani au sortir de l'elysée
quelques minutes après il dit non je ne
plierai pas aux injonctions du chef de
l'état quelque part c'est un
affaiblissement très fort de l'autorité
du chef de l'état alors vous avez dit
est ce une fidélité et fidélité à quoi
est ce une loyauté au parti le parti
n'existait pas fidélité à aider d'abord
gérard était d'abord un engagement
derrière le candidat emmanuel macron à
un moment de crise notamment pour la
droite et le centre
et nous voyons bien que tout ça est bien
effrité entre temps on nous a expliqué
au début que ça ne servait à rien d'être
présent dans les territoires
il ya eu beaucoup d'amateurisme dans un
certain nombre de décisions je dois dire
qu'aujourd'hui un certain nombre de ses
députés prennent la mesure de ce qu'est
être tout simplement parlementaire
gérard larcher l'effritement de la
droite c'est terminé vous avez
l'impression que s'est reconstruit tout
ça vous dire je suis resté aux
républicains parce que je pense qu'il ya
une responsabilité politique qu'à
reconstruire un espace entre la
république en marche quand on voit les
difficultés auxquelles elle est soumise
aujourd'hui et le rassemblement national
je pense que si nous le faisons pas nous
faisons une faute vis-à-vis de la
démocratie est dans les temps les plus
difficiles pour les républicains j'ai
décidé d'y rester avec ma sensibilité
gaulliste de gaulliste social mais je
crois que c est une responsabilité
majeure aujourd'hui l air entend se
reconstruire autour d'un projet lr a
quand même le premier groupe au sénat le
premier groupe d'opposition à
l'assemblée nationale à plus de 60 % qui
sont l air ou centristes des communes de
ce pays beaucoup d'une majorité des
départements une majorité des régions
autour d'un projet nous pouvons proposer
une alternative aux français je ne me
résous pas avoir la même image au soir
du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle en 2022
avec le risque d'une inversion de
l'image au soir du 2e tome et qui pour
l'incarner fédérer que ça se voit que
vous appelez de vos voeux est ce que
françois baroin c'est l'homme qu'il vous
faut françois baroin est un de ceux qui
peut qui peut l'être
voilà pourquoi je je prône une méthode
de départage parce que en plus dans
notre tradition
peut-être moins pour la partie qui vient
du centre des chrétiens-démocrates de
notre famille politique pour la parti
gaulliste il est évident qu'il faut un
moment et un carnet reste à arras
blandine rannou ont parlé de primaires
vous employez ce matin le mot de
départage sequi parce que peu importe le
nom ce qu'il faut se départager entre
des femmes et des hommes qui ont des
qualités et comment on pourrait porter
eh bien c'est ce qu'on va imaginer
après les élections municipales
tranquillement sereinement
certains de mes amis ne sont pas du tout
favorables au maintien de la primaire
sans doute faut-il la faire évoluer
moi je dis qu'il faut une méthode de
départage mais qui sont fans un peu
comme un notaire voyez là qui sont ces
femmes et ces hommes gérard larcher est
ce que je ne sais pas ça pourrait être
vous j'ai déjà dit que ben seule
ambition si mes collègues me font
confiance et pour trois ans encore
d'être président du sénat nous sommes il
ya un excellent livre qui a été écrit
avec une de vos concerts marion bord
contre-pouvoir que nous avons fait
paraîtra à l'automne
je pense que le sénat aujourd'hui et
notamment depuis la réforme du
quinquennat
je m'en veux d'avoir voté c'est très
fort du du quinquennat au lendemain du
calendrier oui aujourd'hui le contre
pouvoir réel c'est le sénat ça nous
empêche pas d'avoir voté trois quarts
des textes après amendement et débat
avec l'assemblée nationale mais sur des
points essentiels
c'est au sénat que se joue le contrôle
du gouvernement
c'est aussi à que nous prenons des
initiatives j'ai un autre très bon livre
à côté de moi
gérard larcher le livre de gérard davet
et fabrice lhomme apocalypse now sur les
années et fillon comme fillon revient
enfin vous allez nous dire d'ailleurs
s'il revient apparemment vous étiez si
j'en crois ces deux auteurs effondré
lorsque fillon a fait son attaque contre
sarkozy imagine-t-on le général de
gaulle mis en examen vous allez trouver
que c'est à partir de ce moment là où il
a dévissé au sein de votre parti
je me suis exprimé d'ailleurs sur votre
antenne 2 puis sablé sur sarthe à
l'époque je me souviens extrêmement bien
vous pourriez retrouver l'enregistrement
l'idée imagine-t-on le général de gaulle
en examen je n'étais pas d'accord
d'abord parce que général de gold avait
été lui condamné à mort par contumace et
que je pense que mes savez françois
fillon c'est quelqu'un pour lequel j'ai
du respect pour la carrière qu'il a eue
comme politique comme ministre comme
premier ministre et comme élu
territorial et comme candidat et comme
candidat au monde une bonne car elle ou
il y à lui toute cette succession
[Musique]
informations saisine du parquet national
financier mises en examen tout le monde
sait je n'ai pas lu ses auteurs ou les
avait avant tout le monde
tout le monde sait que j'avais exprimé à
françois fillon qu'il me semblait
difficile qu'il poursuive sa candidature
mais si vous savez lire le bouquin vous
nous direz si si c'est vrai tout ça
frédéric 16 sur les institutions
emmanuel macron avait promis une réforme
des institutions s'en souvient elle
avait commencé à être examinée elle
avait été interrompue par la sphère
benalla c'était en juillet de la
première année du quinquennat le
processus n'a jamais vraiment repris
selon vous cette réforme des
institutions ne reprendra pas elle est
abandonnée
tous les cas nous sommes toujours prêts
à l'examiner sur le premier projet nous
étions total désaccord car
s'affaiblissent et le parlement
notamment le droit d'amendement
c'est une rémunération d'une réforme des
institutions
c'est pas uniquement pour faire plaisir
au président de la république au
répondre à un discours au congrès à
versailles
c'est est ce qu'on fait mieux
fonctionner la démocratie est ce que la
démocratie est plus en relation avec les
citoyens
est ce que la démocratie correspond au
monde d'aujourd'hui
donc nous sommes toujours prêts nous
avons un point de désaccord quand on ne
fait pas fera pas croire que c'est ça
qui a conduit au depor aujourd'hui de
révision constitutionnelle c'est la
question de la proximité la crise de
gilet jaune ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
démontre le besoin des citoyens d'être
représentés et au sénat de manière
d'ailleurs trans 13 transpartisane
certains de nos collègues ne voulait pas
du tout diminution du nombre de
parlementaires ou je te favorable
ajustements mais il était pas question
qu'ils aient plus de 20 départements ou
territoires collectivités ultra marines
notamment qu'ils soient représentés pas
plus de 20 par un seul député un seul
sénateur
je vais prendre un exemple la nouvelle
calédonie où la polynésie
quelle est la taille de l'europe à ce
que vous l'imaginez représentés par un
seul député
c'est la question du de la baisse du
nombre de parlementaires qui étaient
prévues par ce projet et vous dites
qu'ils auraient eu un mari un maillage
d'élus qui aurait été insufflé la
différence était 21
mais pour cela il faut vous savez
réformer la carte électorale notamment
pour l'assemblée nationale si vous
faites c'est de moins de députés et
notamment des députés élus à la
proportionnelle
il faut normalement l' usage républicain
c'est qu'on ne tripatouille pas la carte
électorale jusqu'à un an avant une
élection ça non porte donc à juin 2021
un an avant l'élection législative et
pour réformer cette carte il faut grosso
modo un an de travail avant cette année
autrement dit ça nous porte à juin 2020
très bientôt est-ce que selon vous ce
calendrier est désormais trop âgé pour
nos collègues députés parce que je
rappelle qu'une loi ordinaire et loi
organique que qui concerne l'assemblée
nationale on n'est pas dans la partie
constitutionnel les délais me semble
assez contraint parce que redécouper les
circonscriptions ça n'est pas qu'une
opération d'assemblage de puzzle c'est
de dire à quoi correspond une
circonscription pour un député et sa
bassin de vie s a lieu où les gens se
retrouvent dans lequel il ya une forme
de communauté territoriale
tout ça ça nécessite du temps il ya
aussi des points importants pour voir
l'éclair ça me semble très très court
comment envisagez vous les municipales
des élections importantes pour le sénat
gérard larcher
y at il véritablement une possibilité
pour les républicains pour la droite
gagner de sauver les meubles bref
utiliser le terme que vous voulez
d'abord pour pré 34000 commune
l'élection a lieu sur un projet local
avec des équipes locales ce qui ne veut
pas dire qu'elle n'est pas de
sensibilité politique tout au moins le
chef de file où le maire sortant et ça
se fait d'abord autour d'un projet 2014
avait été pour la sensibilité des
familles
de la droite du centre un excellent cru
que ce soit hors des communes de taille
intermédiaire ou dans les plus grosses
communes puisque je le disais tout à
l'heure plus de 60% des collectivités on
le voit travers de l'élection du
président de l'association des maires de
france
tout simplement françois baroin je pense
que l'élection municipale sélection
d'une équipe et d'un projet à lorient
naturellement quelques grandes villes
dans lequel les enjeux on le voit paris
on le voit lyon on le voit marseille
sont des enjeux plus politique mais
n'oublions jamais que l'enjeu local est
important y compris dans des élections
d'arrondissement ou deux secteurs
je pense à marseille où je pense à paris
à cet égard que pensez-vous de gérard
larcher de la circulaire de christophe
castaner on en parlait dans le journal
de 8h de sofia le pont qui ne recensera
plus la couleur politique des maires
élus dans les communes de moins de 9000
habitants c'est un tripatouillage
commune partis d'opposition dénoncent ou
pas comme les politologues l'ont dénoncé
dans une tribune parue dans le monde
en effet on se prive d'un baromètre
d'évaluation et j'allais dire de la
pensée politique sur le territoire
quelque part on casse le thermomètre on
casque baromètre parce qu'on veut pas
voir en fait la réalité c'est que ces
élections municipales ne devrait pas
être très favorable à la majorité
actuelle et en cassant le thermomètre on
pense qu'on fera illusion
attendons le recours qui a été présenté
devant le conseil d'état
il a été déposé par plusieurs maires il
a été déposée par des formations
politiques
mais ce que disent notamment le cevipof
et bien d'autres politologues d'ailleurs
de toutes sensibilités c'est on n'a pas
le droit dans une démocratie qui doit
avoir la transparence de casser en
quelque sorte
l'observation de ce qui se passe dans le
pays gérard larcher les républicains
gelé dit observe ces municipales en
étant plutôt confiant parce qu'ils
estiment que beaucoup de les
républicains seront
réélu s'il sont sortants bref il y a une
forme d'optimisme à cet égard mais on
aimerait comprendre quel est le projet
des républicains pour la france quel
espace politique
avez-vous entre la république en marche
et les autres partis le rassemblement
national notamment est ce qu'il est
possible d'élaborer un projet de droite
qui soit vraiment différent alors que
par exemple bruno le maire dont il est
largement question dans le canard
enchaîné
aujourd'hui pour son rôle politique
bruno le maire il vient de vos rangs
est-ce que vous avez véritablement une
alternative à ce que veut bruno le maire
gérald darmanin des gens issus de la
droite aujourd'hui au gouvernement
aujourd'hui le secrétaire général
républicain revient pradier un jeune élu
du lot est en charge de préparer un
projet pour cet été qui sera le congrès
des idées mais je le disais ce matin une
analyse au fond le socle qui demeurerait
au président de la république serait
plutôt le soc de la droite et du centre
son socle de gauche se répartit ça
voudrait dire que ferait une politique
de droite et du centre mais rien vous
appliquer vos électeurs avaient regardé
est ce qui réduit la dépense publique
non ils augmentent même jamais nous
n'aurons eu autant de déficits jamais
nous n'aurons eu autant d'emprunts
souverains en valeur mais pas en
pourcentage il faut le reconnaître sous
la droite
enfin enfin jeudi les ted et avant
dernier en europe alors que tout le
monde a réduit c'était un peu la même
chose de sarkozy maintenant est ce que
oui mais on avait la crise de 2008
pardonnez-moi lui il a la crise des
gilets jaunes oui mais c'est pas tout à
fait la même chose que la crise
financière ne permettrait pas de norme
et lui il a répondu avec le carnet de
chèques 17 milliards sarkozy déroule
décentralisation aujourd'hui car le fond
de la pensée du président de la
république c'est la verticalité il n'a
été la décentralisation ça coûte cher
gérald en larcher donc quand gérald
gérard j'ai dit gérard d'adam non non je
suis pas tourcoing et donc
sur la décentralisation je pense qu'il a
peur de faire confiance aux élus et à
l'intelligence territoriale
pas de réponse réelle sur la question
migratoire pas de réponse réelle sur le
communautarisme et et sur la question de
la laïcité
la question de la laïcité et les
majeures aujourd'hui dans notre pays
pas de réponse non plus regarder
l'explosion de la délinquance les
chiffres sont là il ya une vraie
différence entre la politique conduit
emmanuel macron est un projet que nous
devons porter que nous pouvons
construire avec aussi une dimension
sociale qui m'apparaît extrêmement
importante au fond même si une partie de
mes amis sont pas très favorables au
paritarisme au dialogue social
moi vous savez que je suis de ceux qui
pensent que le paritarisme le dialogue
social rénové refonder est un élément
essentiel de la cohésion de notre pays
nous parlions tout à l'heure des
fractures de notre pays parmi les
ciments de notre pays
il ya aussi le dialogue social et le
paritarisme est ce que c'est un peu
facile de dire que le gouvernement ne
fait rien contre le communautarisme qui
est un problème extrêmement difficile à
saisir et auquel il est très difficile
également de répondre qu'est ce que vous
proposez vous très concrètement avec
marcel gaucher nous avons écrit il ya
quelques mois
ateke sur la loi de 1905 de revenir aux
fondamentaux
je le disais tout à l'heure la loi doit
protéger la foi tant que la fois
n'entend pas dimitar est la loi qu'une
fois très concrètement ça veut dire qu'
il faut dialoguer avec les religions il
faut sortir du ministère de la police
d'ailleurs le bureau des cultes pour le
rattaché au premier ministre
il faut répondre aux problèmes qu un
certain nombre de cultes certains soucis
mobilier le culte catholique par exemple
le problème d'un immense patrimoine dont
une partie n'est plus en usage
ecclésiale et lien avec le
communautarisme
parce que quand on ne répond pas aux
problèmes immobiliers aussi bien de
l'islam que des évangélistes
nous créons quelque sorte cet islam ou 7
évangélisme
des garages et des caves il faut
regarder tout cela il faut lutter aussi
contre le salafistes dont je ne pense
pas comme les virois que c'est une
pratique individualiste c'est de
l'isolant collègues d'amis et je pense
plutôt comme d'autres que aujourd'hui
vis-à-vis de la république combattre
l'islamisme radical et le salafisme sait
se battre pour des valeurs de la
république et pour la liberté de culte
de nos compatriotes ou de ceux que nous
accueillons de religion musulmane
gérard larcher sur la réforme des
retraites là aussi on a du mal à saisir
ce que veut la droite
ce que veulent les républicains il ya
une réforme paramétrique bonne nouvelle
et pourtant et vous vous êtes contre
cette réforme des retraites parce qu'il
ya une faute originelle
on n'a pas dit la vérité la vérité c'est
à dire la vérité alors non faute
originelle c'est quoi les retraites elle
repose sur un niveau de cotisation un
niveau de prestation donc un niveau de
pension et l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite
on a tourné autour pour pas prononcé le
mot âge légal
on a eu hp vos haches déquilibre le
grand-père la grand mère et puis on est
revenu aux années de cotisation et
d'ailleurs c'est tout ce malentendu
qu'on a eues avec les organisations
syndicales et professionnelles deux ans
pour ça pour pas se dire la vérité
vous savez moi j'avais la responsabilité
de parler avec les partenaires sociaux
au moment de la primaire de la famille
des républicains et les partenaires
sociaux que je connais bien je les ai
tous rencontrés
je leur ai toujours dit en vérité que
l'âge légal nous ne pouvions pas échappé
ce que d'autres pays européens
connaissent et l'allemagne est à 67 ans
très bientôt
cette réalité là et puis donc il faut le
fixer à quel niveau
l'âge légal c'est il faut un niveau
glissant comme dans d'autres pays en
fonction de l' équilibre
voilà pourquoi quand le conseil d'état
ait dit extrêmement clairement et pointe
du doigt les insuffisances juridiques et
financières est ce qu'on peut demander à
des parlementaires
je suis désolé j'ai pas compris ce que
c'était l'âge glissant je pense que
c'est vous qui glisse et donnez-nous non
à quel niveau il faut les écouter
l'objectif s'avère 64
progressivement puis 65 ans et nous
savons que nous avons là je l' équilibre
jusque à peu près les trois premiers
quarts de ce fiasco que cette réforme
elle n'est pas assez sévère gérard
larcher c'est pas une question de
sévérité
voyez ce que je veux elle n'est pas
sincère mais ça n'a rien à voir avec
l'action des nations d altérité et la
sincérité c'est de dire je peux finance
et donc il est un excellent et un prêt
de financement bien sûr salon emblème je
baisserais mon niveau de prestations ou
j'augmenterai mon taux de cotisation au
rrq si la droite revient ne sera plus
celle rnc là ces soldats droit servira
seule la droite pour le centre ont fait
de réelles réformes des retraites
insuffisantes
nous on nicolas sarkozy puisque vous
êtes obligés de refaire une d'un
progressive nous savions et nous avions
préparé
si nous avions eu la responsabilité de
présider ce pays une réforme des
retraites les retraites avec ces
sénateurs vous savez glee chaque fois
c'est la question que la majorité à
l'assemblée vous pose le gouvernement
veut que le sénat entre dans le régime
général ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui les sénateurs touchent
environ 2000 euros nets de retraite par
mois
après un mandat de six ans alors vous
n'êtes pas vraiment pressé de rejoindre
le régime général vous l'avez dit vous
allez monter un groupe de travail après
la réforme pour en discuter ça pose une
question démocratique plus large au delà
de l'aspect polémique
est-ce que parlementaire c'est une
profession comme une autre dans la
république
nous avons un régime avantageux nous
avons un régime qui nous vient de
l'histoire et qui est autonome
nous avons un régime qui coûte beaucoup
moins cher à l'état que le régime des
députés du fait de notre caisse est bon
pour vous donner un chiffre neuf
millions 9 par an de contribution du
budget contre 67 millions pour les
députés mais nous avons je voulais dit
depuis bientôt deux ans que nous
appliquerons la loi nous allons donc
passer au système universel à point et
nous passerons aujourd'hui dans le texte
il y à une proposition pour ceux nés
après 1975 à partir de 2025 et nous
allons débattre nous allons voir avec
l'assemblée nationale comment nous
pouvons avoir des régimes convergent
souhaitiez poser est aussi et c'est la
deuxième partie 2
autre question est ce que c'est un
métier comme un autre la réponse est non
la réponse c'est qu'il faut aussi
assurer de l'autonomie des
parlementaires donc un régime autonome
mais si lors de lens de 58 parce que
indemnités droit et régime pardonnez moi
que seraient les parlementaires qui
vivraient sous la férule de l'exécutif
vous le dire il y aurait un moyen de
pression via vos retrait bien par
uniquement ça mais c'est l'ensemble il
ya une ordonnance en 1958 général de
gaulle en 58 n'avait pas présupposer
extrêmement favorables au régime
parlementaire et pourtant il l'a protégé
parce qu'il savait que c'était
extrêmement important de le protéger et
nous devons conduire cette réforme en
donnant en même temps aux parlementaires
les moyens de leur autonomie de leur
indépendance
ça n'est pas un métier tout à fait comme
les autres c'est souvent la marque de
rupture de carrière et je voudrais
rappeler simplement que les sénateurs
prennent leur retraite un peu après 71
ans sur la démocratie et les
institutions précisément une convention
de citoyens tirés au sort est en train
de débattre de la transition écologique
vous l'avez vu c'était l'une des
réponses des manuels macron à la crise
des gilets jaunes
cette forme de démocratie délibérative
mais pas représentative ils n'ont pas
été élues évidemment ça fait du bien ça
re génère la démocratie oui vais par
exemple nous avons mis nos en ligne au
sénat mais on a déjà un succès les
principes du retour du droit de pétition
qui était dans notre constitution mais
qui était tombée hors d usage
nous avons la possibilité sur le site du
sida de mettre en place des ip tition
qui seront ouvert à la signature pour 6
pour une période de six mois j s'il ya
cent mille signatures
la conférence des présidents examinera
soit la demande une proposition de loi
soit d'une mission de contrôler toutes
ces réalités là je crois que la
démocratie représentative l essentiel de
la démocratie mais n'exclut pas du tout
la démocratie participative
d'ailleurs il ya bien longtemps que les
maires le vive la démocratie
participative sous une forme parfois
organisées je pense aux conseils de
quartier ou tout simplement dans le
dialogue avec les citoyens
mais généralement la droite les
républicains sont pas très favorables à
des choses un peu
horizontal le référendum par exemple sur
aéroports de paris une première quand
même trouvez pas qu'il ya là quand même
ou bien retournement de situation ou
bien un opportunisme politique et à
nicolas sarkozy quand on doit la
possibilité d'avoir ce type de
référendums c'est sa modification
constitutionnelle de 2008 c'est pas la
gauche qui l'a fait c'est l'europe
les sénatoriales de septembre puisque en
septembre il va y avoir une élection qui
portera sur les 178 sénateur de la série
2 comment vous la voyez cette élection
gérard larcher et les sénateurs ils sont
élus par la trame des 550 mille élus
locaux de ce pays à noter d'ailleurs les
municipales sont importants et et ça
veut dire d'ailleurs
c'est la trame des élus qui ont seuls la
confiance majoritaire des français en
ces moments de défiance vis à vis des
politiques des médias vis-à-vis des
élites nous avons la trame de ceux qui
ont la confiance des français
ce sera donc lié aux résultats des
élections municipales près de 96 % du
corps électoral est issu des élections
municipales et nous verrons ce qu'il en
résultera aurait simplement dire à vos
auditeurs qu'il imagine peut-être pas
62% des sénateurs n'était pas sénateurs
le 30 septembre 2014
nous avons un très profond
renouvellement au sénat et nous avons en
quelque sorte une génération issue du
territoire à ses nouvelles
moi je n'appartiens pas cela mais je
dois dire qu'il n'y aurait pas homo
d'être un homme politique dans la
carrière depuis longtemps gérard larcher
mais je trouve qu'ils apportent à notre
assemblée une forme de vitalité de lien
et que l'expérience de ceux qui ont vécu
sur le territoire depuis longtemps et
leur expérience eux aussi issus du
territoire
c'est une richesse pour notre assemblée
une garantie d'autonomie salut au sénat
ont dit jamais oui par discipline et
jamais non par dogmatisme vous êtes
saisis des questions de bioéthique
gérard larcher c'était le rôle du sénat
d'abord c'était la responsabilité du
sénat
d'examiner un projet de loi sur les
questions de bioéthique
nous sommes cette semaine en train
d'examiner un certain nombre de sujets
majeurs sur l'embryon sur les cellules
souches et sur des sujets et faut-il
borné ou non la science nous nous
pensons qu'il faut lui apporter des
limites et là dessus il ya une forme de
convergence entre la pensée d'agnès
busin et d'une majorité de collègues et
celle d'avant soit apaisée
nous avons voté majoritairement la paix
main mais nous avons un débat apaisé car
nous sommes très attentifs aux questions
d'éthique et de dignité humaine gérard
larcher et la pensée les convictions de
françois-xavier bellamy et les vôtres
par exemple là dessus elles peuvent vite
dans une même famille politique nous
n'avons pas toujours les mêmes choix je
m'étais exprimé sur le sujet de la
richesse d'une famille politique c'est
pas de s'exclure les uns les autres mais
d'essayer à un moment se retrouver au
coeur du ring en quelque sorte pour
porter dans la diversité un certain
nombre de valeurs et la question du
respect j'allais dire de l'homme en tant
que tel d'une question qu'on peut
partager compris en avant en ayant
parfois des réponses un peu différente
gérard larcher président du sénat et
membre du parti des républicains